on this episode we got shut down
okay don't worry we'll just send it all
right guys you heard the man we have to
listen
on this episode stick with me here we go
to the gym with me
alright question of the day what's going
on with your workout regimen on this
episode
chase visits me thanks for me on the
show me ask you very much
bye people we're out we're trying
something new here obviously you're
you're recognizing something different
in your Facebook and YouTube
environments I talk about London because
that's where I'm at
clean up guys on this episode I invite
the interns on this episode the winners
join me let's clap it up
yeah I'm Dallas Hutchinson's my name is
I'm my name is Matthew Jane
I never sneeze
that was super rare I'm telling you guys
episode 1 - I'm telling you episode 122
episode 129 is gonna have some of the
great rarities something you'll see
all-time great moments in the show's
history on this episode I have my dad
join me I mean I'm very proud what this
family were able to accomplish and what
a special what the re of Ag I mean you
know special kids deftly it's very all
about the thought that you could ever
complain about success it's so insane to
me
you don't need to do stop bullshitting
sleep less [ __ ] don't watch TV like I
don't know like don't make a video with
Gary Vee answer somebody's [ __ ]
question got it pumps to be doing the
show in front of a bunch of the
vaynermedia Peaks which is exciting for
me black and white very good I'm well oh
yeah good
I'm not moving Kiera let's go again
short you move [ __ ] wise I was
in the bonus question on this episode I
answer questions in front of hundreds of
my friends